trouble night could have been released
two decades ago it's an old-looking game
that pedals old ideas with a save the
girls story that's just as old as
everything else and you know what none
of that stuff matters whereas many retro
style games have a modern twist of some
sort trouble night Basques in its
archaic nature it's old old old old and
that old Nintendo in fact it highlights
just how timeless some ideas are shovel
knight is old dusty and really
entertaining trouble tonight is a
straightforward platformer in the
demands precision and determination
winding a way through dangerous locales
with your trouble at the ready you
vanquish baddies while collecting all
the treasure within secrets backing you
to explore every surface bosses taunt
you with their pattern based attacks
special items imbue you with magical
powers and platforms cruelly vanish
beneath your feet if you cut your teeth
on games during the NES era there are
tons of references to keep you smiling
the bosses resemble those from Megaman
using Knights as a standard for robot
masters visiting a town brings back
strong memories from Zelda to The
Adventure of Link as you Pogo on top of
enemies it's hard to not be reminded of
Scrooge McDuck in duck tales that are
subtle and overt references throughout
trouble Knights which is what you'd
expect from a retro game but what's
important here is that shovel knight
doesn't dwell on references to games of
the past rather it's the satisfying
combat encounters that grabbed my
attention luring a knight to lower it
shield while I danced around him or
deflecting fireballs back at an enemy
wasn't fun because I have done something
similar years ago those moments were so
thrilling because of the finesse
required to succeed of how pleasing it
was to foil an enemy's plans to triumph
even when the tide was turned against me
this is true for the sense of discovery
as well yes the levels are linear but
hidden passageways are there for those
who crave more treasures shovel knight
has smart level design that not only
hides its treasures well but also
presents enough variety to keep you on
him
flaming platforms crushing chandeliers
and darkening flashes keep you waiting
for the unexpected the special items you
collect grant you a flaming missile or
temporary invincibility in using these
in unexpected situations gave even more
variety to the proceedings I could plot
my own strategies against the fauces
maybe I toss a couple deadly Spears or
jump repeatedly on its head a game gave
me tools so I could be creative but
there's the heck up as much as I love
shovel Knight the first time through
when I started a new game + well things
weren't quite as exciting so much of
shovel knight was built on surprises and
where items were hidden what enemies I
would face when I revisited stages that
appeal faded away so it struggled to
hold my attention now it's not a bad
thing that a game was only ridiculously
fun one time through but the best games
out there the ones that inspired shovel
knight I could play those over and over
again shovel knight lost its luster once
it surprises vanish this is partly
because of well the games not that part
the checkpoints are so forgiving that
dying never felt like much of a
punishment and though I loved concocting
new ways to kill bosses the first time
through the creative potential is a
little lacking so while I was enamored
the first time through I was going
through the motions when I returned so
shovel knight would have been loved no
matter what era came out its inherent
charms are timeless and it's not a
classic and said it's an amazing remind
with a great game design ages that never
dies that simple mechanics and still be
immensely satisfying but it's not a game
I need to return to new game+ is an add
interesting wrinkles and without any
surprises in store there's nothing
demanding my intention Gemini is a great
recreation of what I grew up with but
doesn't have the longevity or
inventiveness to be great in its own
right